[Music]
Wells Adams with sarah hyland off her
feet with an incredible bachelor style
birthday surprise anyone could have
gotten swept up on Thursday the bachelor
in paradise star helps Sarah ring in 27
early with a helicopter ride to
California's Catalina Island
check out these adorable pics the Modern
Family star shared from their adventure
oh that was crazy
later in the day Adams joined Highland
for Thanksgiving where he met her
parents and brother
then on Friday Highlands actual birthday
The Bachelorette alum shared this
black-and-white photo with the sweetest
message for his leading lady listing the
top five ways helicopters are like Sarah
as for our favorite that would be number
one quote they make you feel like you're
floating last week Highland opened up to
ET about how her boyfriend has two
families to impress I think the more
stressful thing is to like meet them to
meet like the second family which is not
only the dumpee family but the entire
cast and the entire crew not all of our
writers and everybody that's involved
like that's the second family that is
like I think the most terrifying thing
for guys that I date
[Music]
you